science progresses
independent of the whims of jealousy and
human nature so physics will March
forward no matter how jealous people are
or how much backstabbing there is
because that's human behavior you can't
stop it that's just the way it is
welcome everybody to the into the
impossible podcast I am your fearful
host Dr Brian keing and this is now
Professor mitcho kaku's second
appearance on the into the impossible
podast
because of a mistake by an unknown
unnamed uh podcast software which I will
not repeat but anyway today is going to
be even bigger and better than ever
because so much has happened just in the
week or so since I first interviewed
miio and he is so gracious and so kind
to come back uh given his busy schedule
and his newly christened bestselling
book The God equation which is one of my
favorite books in recent memory Mito how
are you very good honored to be on your
show it's really such a pleasure and I
want to congratulate you from all of us
in the Arthur C Clark Center for human
imagination on uh not only the success
of of the book you know in terms of
commercial success but in terms of the
critical Acclaim that it has received
it's made a tremendous impact and I want
to uh begin with maybe this version of
the podcast to to make up for for past
uh sins on my part uh maybe it was a
message to me uh do you believe in in
kind of uh the the mysterious ways of
serendipity Mito that maybe this was for
a reason that we got to go together
again for the second time well um
destiny of course is a very elusive
quantity but as I mentioned in my
speeches I think I think Humanity has a
destiny not individuals but I think
Humanity has a Destiny the universe is a
chess game and our destiny is to figure
out the rules of Chess and the rules of
Chess of course give you the god
equation and then we want to become
Grand masters of chess
I think that's the destiny of the human
race to master the rules of Chess that
is the god equation and then to become
Grandmasters and when we talk about
Chess we we actually didn't have a
chance to talk about this last time but
maybe this is a good time as any to go
into this I have a theory that we're
already being beaten by computers and
artificial intelligences when it comes
to chess do you think an artificial
intelligence could ever create a game
like chess in other words does it have
the creative power even in a futuristic
Alpha Infinity type computer could it
create a game that humans would find
amusing or or or perhaps could it create
a complex game not just solve and beat
us but could actually outdo us and
create a game such as chess well first
of all let's take a look at artificial
intelligence today versus artificial
intelligence maybe the next century and
beyond uh when we look at robots today
what animal are they equivalent to if
you were to compare a robot today to an
animal they would be equivalent probably
to a cockroach you could put a cockroach
in a forest and the Cockroach would
immediately find food shelter mates you
take our most advanced military robot
and put it in the forest so what happens
it falls over gets lost can't even get
up again but eventually they will be as
smart as a mouse then as smart as a rat
then as smart as a rabbit then as smart
as a dog or a cat and by the end of the
century who knows when I think they'll
be as smart as a monkey now monkeys are
self-aware therefore they are
potentially dangerous as well and we at
that point we should put a chip in their
brain to shut them off if they ous
thoughts now that's because monkeys are
self-aware now dogs on the other hand
dogs are
confused you see dogs think that we are
a dog and that's why they obey us
because there's a picking order in a
wolf pack and that's why they obey us so
we have a long way to go I think before
we have a a device that is as creative
and as spontaneous and Innovative as
human beings I think of you as a master
Storyteller and people uh you know that
you have a a wonderful reputation as a
hardcore scientist but I interviewed in
the intervening weeks since we spoke I
interviewed Anil degrass Tyson and he
and I spoke about many things including
impact of race and issues of race Etc
but but mainly about science and and
popularization as well as the fact that
he can no longer walk down the street
and not get recognized uh the day after
you and I record our episode uh you and
I appeared together in William Shatner's
unexplained the episode about the moon
and I was just remarking to one of my
kids came in and said wow dad you're
you're really important look look how
look who you're appearing with and I
said who Captain Kirk William Shatner he
said No Mitch
Kaku how do you take your Fame and
celebrity how do you handle it and still
do serious work when you know that some
physicists look down on those of us who
reach out to the public how do you see
the balance between your public Persona
on TV and movies uh with uh with your
private productive Persona as a
physicist well there's a sad story about
Carl Sean the great astronomer he of
course was a publishing astronomer made
contributions to the field of astronomy
made discoveries
however he was nominated for the
National Academy of Sciences that's the
nation's highest scientific advisory
body it advises the United States
Congress for example but the
mathematicians at Yale revolted and when
the vote was taken they basically said
he is a quote M
popularizer and they voted him down and
that was kind of an embarrassment to
Carl Sean but now we have figures like
Stephen Hawking who have impeccable
credentials as a research scientist and
so they're in a situation where they can
say yes I want to reach the people I'll
be able to touch people's hearts and
Minds because of course ultimately who
pays our salary it's the taxpayers
ultimately and you know during the Cold
War all we had to do was go to Congress
and say one word one word that we be get
funding and that word was
Russia then Congress would come back to
us with two words and those two words
were how much well those days are gone
we had to learn to sing for our supper
and that was very dramatic in my field
elementary particle physics and
relativity in the 90s when the super
collider was cancelled that's the reason
why American particle physics is two
generations behind Europeans because
there of course they have the large hon
collider what happened during those
hearings well in the in the last days of
hearing one Congressman asked a
physicist and I quote will we find god
with your machine if so I will vote for
it well the poor band didn't know what
to say so he said we'll find the exbos
on well you can hear the Jaws hit the
floor of the United States Congress
billions of dollars for another goddamn
subatomic particle the vote was taken
and the Machine was cancelled and since
then we physicists have racked our
brains
how should we have answered that
question because it'll come up again
will we find god with your machine I
would have answered it differently I
would have said God by whatever signs or
symbols you ascribe to the deity this
machine the super collider will take us
as close as humanly possible to his
greatest
creation Genesis this is a Genesis
machine it will C the greatest day in
the history of the
universe its birth unfortunately we said
hgs B on and American particle physics
experimental physics was set back two
generations think about that so we
physicists have to learn to sing for our
supper hey friends just a short request
to ask you to use your thumb while my
thumb is occupied to leave a like on
this video and don't forget to subscribe
it really helps us with the algorithm
now back to the episode there's an awful
lot of God that makes its way in into
things like the God particle which I
think it was a pejorative originally for
the God you know hyphen D and particle
by Letterman uh but but I wonder you
know if if there isn't a metal layer on
a higher level this this feeling that
when you cancel something the money goes
back into the same field in other words
there was a jealousy just as there was
of Carl Sean and I heard that story uh
from from people that knew Carl
obviously but also there was almost like
a jealousy of of particle physics that
it enjoyed a whole Century or half of a
century at least of being the most
preeminent regarded field of physics uh
where in physics was the preeminent form
of of intellectual activity of all human
beings at least where you had people
like fem men and others a swinger
escorted by uh armed guards to go to
physics meetings like I can't even
imagine you know going to theas or the
aps meeting and having an armed guard
next to me I mean that would be kind of
fun actually but uh but you know towards
the end of the century people started to
think well you know what are we getting
what's the return on investment and uh
there have been you know some books
written about this Peter white has
written about this Lee Mullen has
written about this how do you answer the
critics that say there haven't been
major Revolutions in fundamental
particle physics since the
1974 what November Revolution I think it
was called how do you answer those
critics that say that fundamental
physics has been in a holding pattern uh
for 50 years almost well there is a
unspoken pecking order
where as you pointed out some people are
jealous that elementary particle
theoretical physicists are at the top of
the pyramid and computer scientists call
this physics Envy physics Envy meaning
that in physics things get simpler every
year but more powerful so when I write
an equation down I know that on the
other side of the mil QA Galaxy there's
an alien with a different notation
writing the same same equation because
these equations are Universal now you
can't say that about Shakespeare you
can't say that about great works of art
because of course they are particular to
the planet Earth specifically Homo
sapiens on the planet Earth in a certain
Century in a certain country with a
certain language while physics
especially elementary particle physics
is universal plus it gets simpler every
year while English literary criticism I
have a lot of respect for them some of
them are my friends who engage in
English literary criticism they wonder
what did James Joyce really mean by that
and PhD thesis by the hundreds are
written about what did Hemingway really
mean by that sentence so English
literary criticism becomes more
complicated every year theoretical
physics is the opposite you could put
all the equations of the universe the
fundamental equations on one sheet of
paper one sheet of paper now can you do
that with Shakespeare can you do that
with Hemingway no but physics the
fundamental laws of physics can be put
on one sheet of paper topof the line Ein
sze equations one inch long then the
stand of model which is ugly as Sin but
you can put it on a sheet of paper the
theory of almost everything a bunch of
gibberish you know 10 lights across
that's the sted model and it didn't have
to be that way and so that's where
physics Envy comes into the picture if
you are a computer programmer tirelessly
working about computer games or
algorithms for Wall Street it gets
complicated but physics get simpler and
more Universal and more powerful as the
years go by now are people jealous as a
consequence yes but that's human nature
science progresses
independent of the whims of jealousy and
human nature so physics will March
forward no matter how jealous people are
or how much backstabbing there is
because that's human behavior you can't
stop it that's just the way it is for
example when I got my PhD back in the
1970s from the University of California
at Berkeley if you were doing String
Theory people laughed at you they
snickered in fact John Schwarz was in an
elevator with Richard fan and Richard
fan was joking with John Schwarz and
said John how many dimensions are you in
today in other words fem men like to
make fun of everybody especially string
theorists and so the point of raising is
we are humans therefore we engaged in
Petty kinds of behavior but let me tell
you my favorite Fineman story I gave a
talk on Stringfield Theory which is my
creation it summarizes all string theory
in an equation about one inch long and I
gave a talk at Aspen for the senator of
theoretical physics Fineman and gilmon
two giants were in the audience Fineman
being famous for putting down the
speaker fman comes up to me after my
talk and he says well I don't
necessarily agree with SH Theory but
then he said your talk was one of the
most beautiful talks I have ever heard
in other words summarizing this vast
Treasure Trove of equations of string
theory into an equation that is one inch
long he said your paper was gorgeous oh
well that's High Praise indeed I'm going
to come back with a rhetor rep uh from
Fineman himself which is that uh he said
I don't care how beautiful your theory
is if it doesn't agree with the
experiment it's wrong and you lost a bet
a few years ago with a commentator John
Horan uh so-called bet over the uh
String Theory uh provability before 2020
no the Nobel Prize with the Nobel Prize
me the Nobel Prize yeah I forgot what
what did I say well ignore what I said
but anyway you made a bet uh under the
opes of the long bets Foundation a
public Arena
uh that it would be there would be
evidence uh for uh for either super
String Theory membrane Theory or some
other unified theory describing all the
forces of nature that would result in a
Nobel priz so you lost that bet you paid
up uh of course uh unlike some other
people who didn't pay up certain bets
but we're not going to talk about those
people uh so I want to ask you in line
of Fan's saying um how long do we would
you make that bet again would you make a
10-year long bet with me uh how do you
feel about the process prospects for I
mean I don't like the Nobel prizes these
posters will tell you as a as a kind of
a sign of God's you know kind of
divinity bestowed upon mankind because
it's just given out by Mortals Mo mainly
in Sweden uh and so who are they to
judge us but but anyway I want to ask a
question um are the prospects getting
bigger or would you dispute that quote
with Fineman uh that that the sinan Nan
is experimental testability no I agree
with Richard fan and also Carl San Carl
Sean said remarkable claims require
remarkable proof and two weeks ago there
was an earthquake that emerged outside
Chicago at fery laboratory an earthquake
that everyone is talking about in
physics experimental or theoretical a
deviation has been found in the standard
model look I got my PhD in
1972 the standard model was already in
place when I got my PhD and it held sway
for 50 years for 50 years we have no se
seen no crack in the standard model even
though it's the ugliest Theory ever
proposed in the history of science 36
quirks and antiquarks three generations
of identical particles three parameters
that can be adjusted at will it's ugly
it is Clumsy it's a theory that only a
mother could love and found a crack in
it just two weeks ago people are jumping
on it we have four forces we have
gravity the electromagnetic force and
the two nuclear forces they could be a
fifth force a fifth Force could emerge
from the ferm Laboratories outside
Chicago and that's causing excitement
and what are the candidates for a fifth
Force well it means a new particle
string theory has lots of particles we
here uh in this universe of ours we are
the lowest Octave of the string in fact
if Einstein had never been born we would
have discovered general relativity as
the lowest vibration of a string however
the string is higher octaves just like
your piano just like your violin has
Hier octaves the Hier octaves could be
manifested who knows for sure in this
new discovery plus we have satellites
going up Lisa a gravity wave detector in
out of space that may detect evidence of
a preig bang universe predicted by
String Theory not to mention the fact
that the Chinese
the Japanese and the Europeans are now
proposing a successor to the large Asian
collider which may very well probe the
periphery of string theory not to
mention the fact that there are ongoing
experiments right now testing for
deviations from luden's laws of gravity
as predicted by String Theory so in
other words there are plenty of
experiments that are now being conducted
the people who don't know this are the
critics right you know I was taking the
opportunity between the previous time we
conversed till today to look at some of
your papers from the 1970s and I found
them remarkably preent uh for those that
uh you know have any doubt of mito's
calculational computational prowess uh
you've been at the New York uh at Cooney
for a long time I didn't realize how lot
that you were there since
1974 after getting your PhD you work
with mandal Stam right as your adviser
yeah that's right so you are a proponent
and what I thought we'd do this time uh
is talk a little bit with you uh playing
the role of the of the of the defender
of Rivals to string theory words I'm
going to pretend I am the proponent of
string theory and I'm kind of agnostic
I'm an experimentalist I like to adhere
to experimental test obviously and even
the cosmological test we'll get into
that in a bit but I want to say act as
the defender and I want you to kind of
support pick a theory that's a rival in
your mind it could be luke quantum
gravity it could be my friend Eric
Weinstein's geometric Unity um what did
those theories have that can rival the
lonian which you made not only the first
relativistic field Theory thereof but
you wrote down L that included matter
field so these other models that you
support in this argument uh and in
simulated uh space you support Loop quum
gravity and and other things they don't
even include Fons so what what could you
say about these Rivals to string theory
to defend them well first of all what is
the Criterion for to win a Nobel Prize
and be declared the next Einstein you
have to satisfy three things three
things and you will go down in history
as the next Einstein your theory your
grin must first of all have general
relativity in it second it must have the
staed model and more but at least the
staed model third it has to be
mathematically consistent that is finite
and an anomaly free that's it and then
the question is how many theories can
satisfy these Criterion let's take them
one at a time there's something called
Loop Quantum Gra gravity a very
ingenious Theory I must admit however it
has no electrons no protons you and me
we're not part of loot quantum gravity
it's a theory of Pure Gravity and Pure
Gravity is probably mathematically
inconsistent if you calculate the first
fman Loop diagram I'm pretty sure it is
Divergent uh we've done it on computers
we haven't done it in the regime for
glot point of gravity but for
perturbative Gravity we done it on a
computer and it diverges it blows up
it's infinite but what about all the
other attempts Irwin Schrodinger tried
to create a unified field Theory he's
the founder of quantum mechanics for
God's sake he failed he thought that it
was again a pure gravitational Theory no
electrons no protons and so you go down
the list and then you begin to realize
oh my God there's nothing left except
one and the only thing that is left is
is string theory now if you don't like
string theory what is your main attack
your main attack against String Theory
would be as follows first is it a theory
of anything or a theory of nothing or a
theory of everything in other words
where is the beef where is the
experimental proof and I have a rebuttal
to that second it doesn't predict our
universe it predicts a Multiverse of
universes
and which one is ours so a theory of
everything becomes a theory of anything
and so it has no predictive power you
cannot predict anything a priority using
string theory so those are the two most
powerful arguments against String Theory
which I will be glad to address yeah and
I will further attack uh I will further
attack a loop quantum gravity by by just
saying that the the foundation on which
it's based maybe this is a technical
point but my understanding is that there
are hamiltonian formulations of it but
not l grangian formulations or perhaps
those don't exist can you specify or or
explain why is that an important
distinction when you say the Gran of of
string theory that you worked on from
the 1970s until today um is the C is
kind of the necessary uh you know
ingredient of a of a of a starting point
for a universal Theory of Everything uh
can you say why the Lop quantum gravity
should even be considered given that it
doesn't have a you know fully fleshed
out standard model of particle forces
and Fields why is it that relativity and
the quantum theory don't like each other
why should God have a left hand and a
right hand that fight each other that
don't coordinate I mean that's
ridiculous why would God create two
hands that don't coordinate with each
other well the problem is that gravity
is based on smooth surfaces smooth
elegant beautiful gorgeous manifold
well matter is based on chopped up
particles that you grind up and spit out
like a meat grinder it's all cut up and
so L quantum gravity which in which
field does it fall into it falls into
the gravity field but says nothing about
electrons protons quarks meons the
hundreds of scient the hundreds of
particles that we have analyzed is a
theory of Pure Gravity and therefore it
is is simply not a unified field Theory
which even the creators of the theory
acknowledge they be the first ones to
say that their theory is not a rival the
string theory it's just an alternative
an alternative for Gravity but not for
electrons protons quarks you and me
basically and so we have a situation
where of all the theories proposed these
two theories relativity and quantum
theory don't like each other when it's
based on smooth manifolds like
trampoline nets and the other one is
based on chopped up particles and how do
you combine these two the only way to
combine these two is through music and
that is the lowest Octave of the string
contains all of Einstein's theory if
Einstein had never been born we would
have discovered the entirety of gen
relativity as the lowest note of a
vibrating string which is I think
amazing in fact the staed model is also
there among the the lowest octave the
problem is everything else is there too
universes that don't exist universes
where protons are unstable and matter
cannot form universes that are uh
different dimensional they're all there
in string theory how does it select out
our universe out of this wide range of
universes right yeah so for me one
question I've I've come up with I've
spoken to many many uh proponents of
string theory from C bafa John presal
others and you know the question I keep
getting getting Not So Satisfied by
their answers I'm going to pose to you
which is that it's not at all clear that
uh that having somebody like my former
guest lanard susen on um saying that
there's a landscape of possible vacuous
States uh and this is told to me as an
experimentalist to imply an almost
unbounded number of possible string
theories string values of fundamental
constants values of masses of the
fironic sector the bosonic sector you go
you can describe in any way you like it
can construct a landscape of possible uh
of universes that uh we find ourselves
just in one and there's always the
anthropic kind of uh result that that
then that that then implies but it's not
all clear to me miio and maybe you can
um you know you can clarify for me but
why would these law other universes not
also have laws where one plus one
doesn't equal two because what they call
addition is what we call quaternionic
multiplication in other words that the
laws of math the loss of logic why
couldn't they differ from Universe to
Universe in the string landscape well
let me try to answer this question by
posing another question how many
solutions of Newton's laws are there
Newton lived in the
1600s how many solutions are there
there's a solution for a gun for a
rocket ship for a pellet a marble a
spinning top in fact there an infinite
number there's a landscape there's a
landscape of infinite sequence of
solutions to Newton's laws of gravity
Max's equations for a light how many
solutions of Max's equations are
infinite number so how do you determine
which one is your Universe you have to
tell me you have to tell me that we're
describing a rocket today or we're
describing the ire State Building today
you have to tell me this you have to
tell me quote the initial conditions
okay same thing if I have a theory of
everything not String Theory but an
alternative if I have an alternative
Theory of Everything it has the same
problem it will give you an infinite
number of solutions depending on your
initial conditions so where do the
initial comes where do the initial
conditions come from you tell me now at
the instant of creation we're talking
about 10 the minus 33 cm with the length
of energy that's the energy of the Big
Bang itself the universe started off as
a Quantum fluctuation in the vacuum now
given that fact what are the initial
conditions at the instant of creation we
don't know that's an experimental
problem that's for you guys that's where
the weak link is experimental physics
when the experimental physicists tell us
that we're talking about a spinning top
uh a bullet a rocket ship then we can
Sol equation but until the
experimentalists tell us what the
initial conditions of the universe were
we're stuck because that's an
experimental problem in other words it's
your fault I'll take the blame for that
that's the Le least thing I've been
accused of today alone Mito but let me
refer you to work done by David spurgle
Daniel Holtz Maya Fishback and Chris
Paro back in
2018 which is titled limits on the
number of SpaceTime Dimensions from
gravitational wave
170817 uh which very severely limited
and constrained the dimensionality uh to
be very close to three dimensions of
space in contradistinction with an
uncertainty of at the few percent level
from a single event by the way I mean
this will only get better so does this
not rule out vast you know vast tracks
of land many acres in the string
landscape I mean almost in
infinitesimally shrinking it to to a
single if you like battery condition
because as you know Newton's laws are
are very different in the universe of
three spatial Dimensions versus two or
one or far four or five so do these
limits shake your confidence at all in
in large extra Dimensions or in in
string theory as a as as a as a whole no
uh these are all speculations I think
these speculations are healthy but until
we have the god equation that is the
final formulation of string theory all
these are nothing but speculation now
let me explain my equation string field
Theory allows you to summarize String
Theory into an equation a little bit
more than an inch long in fact I publish
it in my my book the the the god
equation however that's not enough we
now have the 11th Dimension coming in
coming in from Princeton's physicist
department and we know that there are
membranes now do we have a string field
theory for membranes and strings the
answer is no now maybe somebody who's
listening to this program will be
inspired to write down the field theory
of membranes and strings I have a word
of advice for them when you find this
final equation the god equation tell me
first we'll publish together and we'll
win the Nobel Prize together and we'll
be declared as a joint creators the
successors to Albert Einstein because
that's what we're talking about we're
talking about the
lren which is probably an inch long
which will summarize both membranes and
strings that could be the whole shooting
match you obviously think geometrically
I remember reading your books in the 90s
and being heavily influenced on them not
quite tempted to become a theoretician
myself but but nevertheless very uh
influenced by you and the and the
Exquisite way that you spoke about um
kind of the two sides of Einstein's
equations you know one kind of marble
and one made of wood and and and
thinking about the hyperspace you know
kind of conjectures are those possible
to re to to rule out with with any
experiment you know as Nathan cyberg
said we we string theorists are very
arrogant if something comes along and
and we uh and is successful we will call
it part of string the in other words if
by saying that we need to you know get
more and more data essentially is there
a falsifiable element to string theory
is there any experiment or combination
of experiments that would cause you miio
to reconsider your uh your claim that
the god equation will will ultimately be
found in other words is there is there
hope uh is it hopeless to convince you
otherwise or because of your deep-seated
convictions and work in the field or is
there really a chance that string theory
could be wrong every theory has to be
testable reproducible and
falsifiable that is what we call science
and there are ways to test String Theory
let me just rattle them off real quick
five ways five possible ways to test
String Theory one is to look for
deviations in the stat of model like
what happened two weeks ago the first
major crack in the stat of model was
found maybe it's the fotino or maybe
it's a higher super symmetric partner of
some of the particles that we see today
predicted by String Theory second Lisa
laser interform space antenna sponsored
by the European space agency and NASA we
want to get a gravity wave detector in
outer space giving us baby pictures baby
pictures of the instant of creation when
emerges from the womb and if we get baby
pictures of the infinite Universe
emerging from the wound maybe we'll find
an umbilical chord an umbilical cord
because String Theory does not stop at
the incident of creation String Theory
goes before the incident of creation
there's a Multiverse of universes out
there and so we can talk about pre Big
Bang physics how do we do that we look
for post Big Bang radiation and then run
the videotape backwards using string
theory equations to get radiation
profile from before the creation of the
universe itself that's number two number
three is dark matter there are
experiments going on right now even as
we speak looking for Dark Matter
collisions with protons the spark
created by such a collision will be
photographed and that could signal Dark
Matter on the earth you see we live in a
wind a wind of dark matter right now
there's Dark Matter penetrating your
body but it's not electromagnetically
charged so it's very difficult to detect
it's like a neutron very difficult to
detect but any day now not sure when it
will happen but we're going to detect
evidence of dark matter in a laboratory
and also dark matter in outer space
fourth we're talking about the fact that
the Chinese the Japanese the Europeans
are now looking at post LHC physics
they're looking at the next generation
of particle accelerators which may find
who knows super symmetry the symmetry of
the string and fifth we're looking for
deviations for D's laws of Gravity the
inverse Square law we learned about in
high school gravity diminishes as the
square of the distance if you're twice
the distance gravity goes down by factor
of four but no one's ever tested that in
your living room so in outer space in
outer space we know that the iners
square wall works for Galaxies works for
stars planets but we don't know whether
it works for your living room or not so
we're going to test it we're going to
test the inverse Square law to see
whether or not there's there's an
inverse cubic or inverse quartic or
quintic corrections to Newton's laws of
gravity so there you have it five
experiments that could be done to prove
that the theory the string theory is a
theory of everything or a theory of
anything or a theory of nothing let me
ask you another philosophical question
which is that and i' I had this
conversation with sir Roger Penrose
after he won his Nobel Prize I said sir
Roger you know you and Steven and and
others worked on the singularity
theorems black hole and uh origin
singularities of course Steven went
astray in some sense and and really made
this case in the Brief History of Time
that that the university merged in the
so-called hardle Hawkings State uh and
that time had no boundary and
effectively can be instantiated uh in
what he called a trick uh in the book
and few people really have read it all
the way through because he says it's a
trick just to think about things
mathematically and then he goes on to
say because of this the universe doesn't
need a beginning and therefore one of
the two roles for God has been
eliminated in other words God had two
purposes according to Steven one was to
in to initiate the universe and the
other one was to uh instantiate the laws
of physics he said that law of property
number one of God was invalidated by the
no- boundary theorem property number two
would be invalidated in his later book
The Grand Design via M Theory what do
you think make of these uh two Clint
first of all does any practicing
theoretical physicist believe that the
no boundary condition is is accurate in
other words it physical instantiation of
time itself is no contains no boundary
because of this Wick rotation that he
did uh in the to the complex plane for
time in uh and and and described in A
Brief History of Time do any of your
colleagues in theoretical physics
actually take that seriously currently
well first of all I am no judge of
Hawkings no boundary theorem I don't
work in that field however to answer
your question am I aware of people who
work on it actively and the answer is no
I don't think personally this is my
personal opinion not objective but
personal opinion is most people think of
it as a curiosity a mathematical trick
you simply add the square root of minus
one to the equations and your
Singularity disappears okay that's a
slight of hand physics is subtle it's
not just a slight of hand that you can
do by putting an extra I in your
equations you don't make your equations
work just because you put an extra
square root ofus one in the equations
but again I'm No Authority in this field
but to my knowledge no one really takes
it
seriously also Hing had another uh
argument against the existence of God he
had several the other one was that the
Big Bang happened so quickly that there
was no time for God to create the
universe the universe was simply uh
there and uh you know to create a
universe it takes a lot of work creating
universe is not not easy and there was
no time to create the universe but you
see string theory is correct then there
was a pre big bang universe a universe
before the Collision of our universes to
create our known universe so a bubble
bath a universes in a bubble bath
bubbles can Collide bubbles can fision
so there's a time before the Collision
of two universes so there's a time
before the Big Bang in string theory
just pivoting a little bit uh I have an
unusual background in that my parents
were both born Jewish biolog ologic Al
Jewish I was then uh baptized in the
Catholic church and then I became an
alter boy in the Catholic church then I
became an atheist uh then I became a a
practicing Jew SL devout agnostic uh you
have a similar background your parents
were Buddhists you were raised
Presbyterian now you call yourself
agnostic explain what agnosticism means
in practice do you do anything that that
theists believe in that they practice do
you go to church or do you stay home
like Richard Dawkins you know some
people have tried to disprove the
existence of God but that's like trying
to disprove the existence of unicorns uh
you can't do it it's logically
impossible to just prove a negative just
come to my daughter's room my daughter's
bedroom is full of unicorns yeah I mean
if even if you say that we look for
unicorns and we can't find unicorns
anywhere somewhere someplace that You'
never looked never even thought of
looking could Harbor a unicorn so it's
very dangerous to say that some things
don't exist so when some people say that
God doesn't exist you can prove it well
maybe God exists in a place that you
didn't look for now I believe in the god
of Einstein so let me explain Einstein
did not believe in a personal God he did
not believe that uh you know your
Christmas presents are given to you
because God wants you to have that
bicycle for Christmas uh you know God
doesn't Smite the Philistines walk on
water or all those things but he did
believe in the god of Spinosa the god of
Beauty Harmony Elegance Simplicity the
world could have been random the could
have the world could have been chaotic
the world could have been messy Universe
could have been awful but here we are as
conscious beings contemplating the fact
that the laws of physics can be
summarized on one sheet of paper now it
didn't have to be that way our universe
is gorgeous think of what our universe
could have been versus what our universe
really is we have conscious life in a
universe has started off in a random
State and so that's why I think that as
Einstein figured humanity is like a
little boy or girl going into a library
for the first time and there's this huge
Storehouse of knowledge and all we can
do get the first book look at the first
page read the first paragraph that's all
we can do but in front of us there's
this ocean of knowledge and it didn't
have to be that way it could have been
messy chaotic ugly random but here we
are in a universe where the laws of
physics the ultimate laws you can write
on a sheet of paper in fact I think you
can get it down to wage well with my
handwriting it would be hopeless to fit
it in anything under than a than a
poster siiz format because I have
terrible humor uh but Mitch I want to
ask a question is it not presumptuous
since we don't have even a grand unified
theory that everybody agrees to in other
words we don't we we have candidates su5
we have Salam we have other candidate
theories as I mentioned um is it
presumptuous is it not like going from
say Einstein unifying the law of gravity
on Earth to the laws of gravity of the
Moon you know from apples to satellites
uh is it would it not be like going from
that to you know the electro week
unification in other words are we
putting you know the cart before the
horse a little bit too much looking for
the god equation before we find the
Jesus equ I I don't the equation just
right below the god equ well some people
talk about a desert that is if you take
a look at the energy of our particle
accelerators they're low energy we can
go to 14 shil electron volts and up to
that point there's hundreds of particles
that we can discover some people think
that beyond that we're going to see a
desert almost no subatomic particles at
all now why is that because the next
energy realm is pump energy that's 10 to
the 19 billion electron volts that is a
quadrillion times more powerful than the
large hyron Collider some pessimists say
that from now with the higs BOS on till
the BL energy there's a desert now we
can't rule it out because we don't know
when super symmetry kicks in now let me
explain symmetry is the language of the
universe symmetry allows you to combine
two things that look dissimilar eal mc²
for example unifies e with M unifies
matter with E and M is the hydrogen of
the Sun and E is the sunlight that we
get from the Sun so we look for symmetry
now symmetry we don't know when super
symmetry kicks in many people believe it
and even the critics of string theory
thinks that super symmetry May kick in
that's a symmetry of the string but when
at what energy will it kick in so there
is a criticism that says that there
could be a desert there no matter how
big a particle it accelerator we build
we will find nothing just the standard
model now I don't believe in that but
you can't dismiss it easily because
there are some people who propose that
idea the idea of a desert I've talked
with um with Sheldon glashow on the
podcast a couple of months back and he's
obviously been a been quite a Critic in
in in some ways of the you know of
string theory as it as it is and even
spoken in terms of of it almost
presenting a danger I I don't want to
get you know back into that kind of
debate but um but I do want to think you
know kind of more broadly when we when
we you know think about uh these these
big items like the existence of a
possible string landscape or the
existence of a Multiverse um you know
what what is it about that that that
necessarily connects to God you know for
example if I go to my neighbor who has a
lab down the hall you know she studies
Keds matter you know field Theory a
particle cense matter sorry cense matter
phenomenology so you know she might be
looking at um at you know churn Simon's
topological defect matter and so how
come they don't talk about God as much
as as we seem to do in the cosmology and
fundamental physics uh theories uh realm
do well it starts with Einstein in the
sense that he said that science without
religion is lame but religion without
science is blind and so if you read his
Works they're littered with references
to God again not the personal God
the god that you pray to the god that
you want to give you get that bicycle
for Christmas no we're not talking about
about that kind of God and the public is
also fascinated by God just a few years
ago on auction the Einstein God letter
went up for auction and people estimated
that it would pull in maybe a few
million few hundred thousand people were
shocked people were shocked that that
collectors were willing to pay million
of dollars to get Einstein's God letter
where he lays out his position on God
that he doesn't believe in a personal
God but he does believe in the god of
Spinosa so it's out there now also in
mathematics there is a God equation in
mathematics if you're a mathematician
you know that certain numbers are sacred
one Zer I and pi and E these are the
sacred numbers of mathematics there's
one equation the oiler equation which
summarizes all these fundamental causes
in one equation that is sometimes called
the god equation of course is pure
mathematics so of what practical
importance is it nothing or very little
anyway because it's pure math however
think about it for a moment God equation
of physics on the same scale as a god
equation of mathematics would unify the
fundamental features of not just math
but the universe because that's what
physics is all about the equations of
the universe and so the fact fact that
there could be a god equation for
physics to me is astounding absolutely
astounding because there's already a god
equation for mathematics but a god
equation for physics would be a theory
of all physical phenomenon with the turn
gives R to chemistry gives R to biology
give rise to you and me give rise to
love everything that we enjoy about the
universe emerging from one equation so I
want to conclude uh this second edition
of our podcast with kind of just a brief
history of your time on Earth you have
an amazing story you were born to
parents I understand that they were in
interred in in World War II uh as
Citizens was an awful Epoch in the uh
American history um did they ever Harbor
resentment towards the government how
did they react on a personal level if
you don't mind describing it it's such a
unique Horror in our history um how did
that did that impact you did it impact
them if you care to talk about that I
would appreciate it first of all my
parents were US citizens but nonetheless
in
1942 uh they were locked up and kept
behind barbwire uh kept behind guns um
kept inside a camp uh their funds were
pretty much confiscated you had two
weeks if you were lucky you had two
weeks to liquidate all your assets and
so it was heartbreaking knowing that
your neighbors your neighbors that
you've known for for a generation
would come up to your house and bid
pennies pennies are the dollar for all
your household heirlooms because you
could only take what you could carry on
your back so they had to liquidate and
again some people had to liquidate farms
uh they had to liquidate um green houses
uh the Japanese were the ones who
drained a lot of the swamp plant of
California and created this Bread Basket
this Bread Basket called California and
a a lot of it was done by Japanese and
after the war they came back and was all
gone they found their neighbors their
neighbors living in their homes and of
course it was after World War II so they
really couldn't say much about it
Supreme Court even though individual
justices have spoken against it to their
credit the court itself has never made a
landmark decision showing that it is
unconstitutional so some people who are
exper in the Constitution say there's a
loophole there that in case of a crisis
uh the McCarron act and other acts could
be reinstated in which case people could
just be locked up and put into the Caps
by the hundreds of thousands 110
thousands Japanese Americans were
incarcerated during that time now my
parents Bas their philosophy was very
practical you pick up the pieces and you
move forward you don't have a chip on
your shoulder of course you want to make
sure it doesn't happen again you want to
make sure it doesn't happen again but
you don't want to have a chip on your
shoulder either and you want to do your
best and
unconsciously I sort of knew in the back
of my mind that if I was going to be
anything in the world I would have to be
quote extra I have to give put more on
the table than the average person no one
told me that but I just sort of figured
it out that if you want to be considered
equal maybe you should be a little
better than equal
but like I said I'm not going to come
out with a chip on my shoulder I think
that we learned the lesson we have to
make sure that the Supreme Court
unconditionally rules that uh as
unconstitutional while it has not yet
done so and I think we'll be in a better
place as a consequence yeah I agree I
mean looking at you know the current
climate where people are going back to
the founding fathers of the country and
and rightfully you know understanding or
wanting to you know um uh put in context
the fact that many of them own slaves I
mean this is in the living memory what
happened to as you say US citizens um
and and not at all to diminish the
horrors and the uh moral uh inexcusable
of of human slavery uh but this is still
within our generation and yet president
you know Roosevelt is held up with such
high esteem and and and so forth by by
many members of society I don't feel
like we've reckon with that with what we
did to our fellow citizens back then and
but I do want to you know uh compliment
you and and your spirit which you know
immediately went to uh you being you
know constructing a a particle
accelerator not far from uh UC Berkeley
where the the the particle accelerator
was born as a young person and maybe
maybe we can close out with that because
one thing I usually ask my guests is um
do you think that creativity Mito can it
be taught um were you born with these uh
kind of creative uh abilities did you
have to work extremely hard at this this
is something Neil degrass Tyson took me
to task for essentially criticizing you
know the assumption that oh he was just
born with a gift were you born with a
gift were you born with the ability to
do hard work which I consider a gift
what do you attribute your success in
terms of your creativity and throughput
as a scientist well my philosophy is
first of all we are all born scientists
we're born wondering where we came from
why the stars shine why the sun shines
we can't help it we're just born
scientists until we hit the greatest
destroyer of scientists known to science
the greatest destroyer of scientists
known to science is Junior High School
when you go to Junior High School
science is made boring science has made
memorization is being the having to know
things that are totally irrelevant to
people's lives you know in the back of
your mind that you're never going to use
that piece of knowledge ever again and
you're more or less right science is not
relevant to people and science becomes
giving names to things uh Richard fan
the Noel had told this story that when
he was a child his father would take him
into the forest and show him uh how how
birds evolve coloration big how they
feed and so on so forth and one day a
bully comes up to findan and basically
says hey dick what's the name of that
bird over there and the young fan did
not know the name of the bird so I'll
paraphrase the bully then says what's
the matter dick you stupid or something
and in that instant find May realize the
difference between science and the
appearance of science that science is
about principles Concepts physical
models and pictures that's what science
is about not giving the names to birds
of course you have to know some names
but that is not science giving the names
to things and so I think that's
something that we have to realize that
young children were born science stist
till is crushed out of them crushed out
of them when they hit Junior High School
reminds me of a joke that I sometimes
tell where I took a a class in
Ornithology uh as an undergraduate at
Case Western Reserve University and um
we studied hard their migration habits
their mating habits their you know their
their dietary habits all these things
about birds their evolution and then the
final exam came and all that was on the
test were uh bird prints and we were
supposed to identify this bird from bird
track that looks like this and this one
and birds have almost all the same
Footprints at least in phenotype so to
speak and I got so frustrated Mito that
I handed in my paper and I didn't put my
name on it in this huge class of 150
students and as I'm storming out fuming
mad the professor says wait wait you
didn't write your name on it and I said
Professor figure it
out I held up my foot um he didn't laugh
and you're not laughing either but
that's okay uh they not all my jokes are
so spectacular but Mito what is
spectacular is your book The God
equation a bestseller in the New York
Times a bestseller on Amazon hundreds of
of thousands of people are going to be
exposed to concept that is mind-blowing
but presented by one of the foremost
experts the person who came up if you if
you're out there my audience is expert
he basically Mitch I think I can brag
for you you you came up with the findan
diagram type Exposition for Strings back
in the early 70s I mean when string
theory was a newborn we talked about its
umbilical chord well the umbilical chord
goes straight through mokaku the father
of Stringfield Theory the governing L
grangian the uh space-time tube diagrams
the Fineman diagrams there are 11 of
them in your original beautiful paper
which is a work of art by the way in a
time when it was very difficult to make
art and uh illustrations and papers but
Mitch I want to thank you so much for
your graciousness your generosity with
your time this our second interview I'm
going to try to salvage some of the
previous one uh but I want to uh
especially commend you on this wonderful
new book The God equation and I'll let
you know in this interview comes out but
for now I want to know I want you to
know how much of a positive wonderful
impact you've had on my Multiverse